alors bon c'est bon ça va vite on a vu
des flics anges non là ils sont cachés
du sérieux je viens du fric ils sont
cachés derrière les stations service on
dirait qu'ils jouent aux cow boys
indiens y en a un qui regarde comme ça
j'en ai vraiment ils sont comme ça ils
se planquent tu vas me regarder comme
d'habitude avant et qu'est-ce qui
surveille la rue pourquoi y'a quoi ici à
des deals nom bien quoi
quelques petits trucs malsain mais en
vain ouais non pas mais ils croient
qu'ils vont rattraper qui comme ça toi
moi c'est pas parce qu'on dirait
vraiment l'effet nikkei la dérive sont
planqués oui et pourquoi tu t'appelles
doc gynéco parce que suis l'homme que
toutes les femmes elles ont en commun
c'est à dire d'un
madame mitterrand
toutes les femmes elles gynéco ouais
c'est pour ça c'est pas un peu dur à
porter non bon ce moment ouais mais
c'est bon quoi tu t'es marié tresques
arrête tes conneries
oui avec qui ça c'est un secret avant
c'est une amie d'enfance
et tu fais pas partie de mon histoire
hammer toi à fond à fond dedans si j'ai
un procès à cause des ministères norme
c'est vrai entrevue le carnage avait
fait des déclarations un terrible on va
penser bien là bas il ya des copains moi
je vais voir bah oui
ouais alors il y avait une histoire tu
sais mais des déclarations de ministères
hammer dans entrevue
et on est poursuivi par le ministère
public
merci ouais ouais grave pour avoir parlé
du ministère pour avoir interviewé
ministère m'a carrément la vue c'est
chaud très bien du très très chaud je
sais qu'on confie la première page mois
s'achevant le cupide ce journal mais je
peux dire que c'était chaud et les mecs
ils ont gueulé en vraiment dur palais
et samedi quatre flics et tout ça
carrément un troisième album ministère
allemand avant enfin oui c'était potes
ouais
bah oui ça fait x je savais d'effacer y
sévit
j'arrive un petit spliff non c'est nous
avons des bons oui tu me rassures bon ok
ce qu'ils attendent ces flics là sérieux
pour y passer la nuit là on la froide
mais je sais pas c'est un quartier très
cool on connaît tout le monde ici les
filles qui travaillent sur le boulevard
s'écoule regarde les gens avec leurs
enfants tout ça c'est parce qu'ils font
là son speed tout seul centre il
s'énerve eux-mêmes et son loto à l'image
quoi ils se prennent la tête tout ça
mais bon ça va
ouais je si toi avec les avec les flics
non
non jamais à part avec ministère amer
comme toi ouais on est dans le même cas
aujourd'hui et vous avez été poursuivie
aussi ministère là ouais y'a un bientôt
au jugement
ouais c'est ça qu'est ce tu risques
moi pas grand chose
ils sont toujours là mais ce tome i et
stomy stomie il risque une grosse amende
et peut-être
non rien d'autre
marche bien tondue
ouais en ce moment on me dit que ça va
bien ça marche bien mais les mecs de
ministère amer il tord veulent pas un
peu d'espacé dans un genre plus non
peujard il était comme ça non c'est pas
variété c'est un esprit ce ministère à
neuf mais toujours en minister and her
say c'est ça la force de ministères
hammers et doc gynéco comme ça ce tome i
qui peut te faire des jeux pleurt avec
le meurtre ou des sacrifices de tous les
bas si en solo on donne tous un truc
différent c'est toujours à l'esprit
peut-être que cool de la borne toi
peut-être que j'ai moins souffert
ouais
ja
c'est comment ta chanson là qu'est ce
qui passe tout le temps la radio et bien
voir le docteur comment la musique je
suis un peu c'est à dieu je te donne
quelques petits trous comme beaucoup de
films tu rêves d'être brenda d'avoir ton
di valle d'insultés ton papa moi j'ai
200 tasses paix et 50 unités
je ne fais que serré et me la raconter
j'ai bluffé denon en pleine prière
j'insulte mon père et j'invoque lucifer
j'ai fourré mon doigt dans ton intimité
écarte les cuisses si tu veux apprécier
ne vient pas chercher les plus grands
chiens du quartier
j'ai déjà piqué toutes les chiens
enragés remonte ton froc quand tu sors
du studio pantin pour promo et m6
rapallo laisse-moi passé shishir et je
suis fons des leurs à part en couilles
je lui prête mais bull moi j'ai le
manche et le ministère roule même à
l'envers si tu ne sais pas le faire mais
soldats sont en guerre et le dock en est
fier si tu veux pécho viens je te vends
des mots m'ont grossistes et virgin
achète en kilos pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux